les conservateurs choisissent leur chef
en fin de semaine et la manière de voter
est vraiment complexe
laissez moi vous expliquer les 13
candidats conservateurs doivent amasser
des points chaque circonscription vaut
100 points il ya trois cent trente huit
circonscriptions donc un total de 30
3800 points toutes les circonscriptions
ont le même poids peu importe le nombre
de membres qui vive pour l'instant c'est
simple mais ça se complique un peu ça
c'est le bulletin de vote conçu les 250
9000 membres du parti est à partir de ce
qui sera écrit sur ses bulletins que les
points seront distribués les membres
doivent classer en ordre de préférence
leurs dix candidats favoris le parti va
tout d'abord calculées les premiers
choix et dans chaque circonscription
l'appui obtenu sera transférée en point
par exemple 30% des votes ça fait trente
points pour gagner il faut qu'un
candidat accumule la moitié des points
disponibles donc au moins seize mille
900 points mais dans cette course des
candidats y en a beaucoup et donc il
faudra fort probablement plusieurs tours
avant de trouver un gagnant
certains croient que 8 ou même dix tours
seront nécessaires mais c'est difficile
à prédire
à chaque tour le candidat qui a la moins
bonne performance sera éliminé les
points qu'ils avaient obtenu ce candidat
là seront redistribuées et ce sont les
candidats qui avaient été inscrits comme
deuxième choix par les membres dont le
candidat est maintenant hors circuit qui
vont obtenir ces points on continue
comme ça
tour après tour jusqu'à ce qu'un
candidat soit élu chef
vous suivez toujours avec ce système de
vote il ya deux éléments clés
l'importance d'avoir des appuis partout
au pays
même dans les régions qui sont moins
conservatrices parce que chaque
circonscription compte et à un poids
égal mais il faut aussi être perçu par
les membres comme un bon deuxième ou
troisième choix et donc comme une
personne qui est rassembleuse des
facteurs qui pourraient brouiller les
cartes et créer la surprise
[Musique]